well we suspected this moment was coming  we didn't know it get here so fast  everything's happening fast now just 36  days into joe biden's doing  administration  we've just learned the united states has  launched airstrikes on several  facilities in syria tonight  we don't know exactly what those  facilities are of course we never will  know  exactly what they are but the operation  the pentagon has just told this quote  sends a clear and unambiguous message  president biden will act to protect  american and coalition personnel  huh okay maybe someone can explain that  in greater detail  of course the strike did send another  message a more important one that  everyone in washington can hear the  defense industry permanent dc  now have their man back in the white  house that didn't take long  for four years they longed more than  maybe anything for more pointless  conflict in the middle east  and is 36 stays in now they have it